SCP-682 Vs SCP-539.
Could the Perfect Distraction take 682’s
attention away from the one thing it cares
about: hatred?
A member of D-class personnel was sent into
SCP-682’s containment chamber, carrying
SCP-539.
Then, the doors were shut behind them.
Terrified that SCP-682 would kill them, the
D-Class threw SCP-539 early in an attempt
to distract it.
As soon as SCP-539 was
thrown, the site experienced
a system malfunction in the containment chamber.
An acid pump was activated
during this malfunction,
trapping SCP-682 for approximately 20 minutes
before it was deactivated by site maintenance
staff.
By the time staff reached the containment
chamber, 85% of 682’s body had been destroyed.
SCP-539 was found nearby, and the D-class
was completely gone.
Three hours later, SCP-682 was completely
recovered, plus an additional pair of legs
grown during the healing process.